taylor it looks like jaw left early with  some type of injury or limp or something  what can you tell us about that yeah  he's getting evaluated now nothing  further i mean we just watched a replay  uh he was going after a dribble and  jordan paul actually grabbed his knee  and yanked it which kind of triggered  whatever happens so i'm actually very  curious to see what happens after that  yeah i mean there's a basketball play i  mean we win we doubled them um and i hit  the ball and i was going for the ball i  mean obviously you don't want to see  anybody get hurt  um  i'm not even that type of player i  respect everybody so  i mean obviously hopefully we get better  hopefully he gets better and  um you know we can see him out there in  this game but you know i don't even play  like that for real that's not my type  game  i guess john did tweet uh broke the code  with a video of that in response to that  we got another game on monday